So my name is Alex Kelly and I'm sitting here with Jackie Tripodi we're at
Lifestyles on Staten Island and this is for the oral history project Visible
Lives oral histories of the disability experience for the New York Public Library.
It is April 2, 2015 and Jackie I just want to
start out if you could tell me a little bit about what brings you here today.
Well I actually work for Lifestyles for the Disabled and I had a meeting in the building
um
Diane Campion who is one of the public library employees said to me you know we're doing
something exciting to educate people about people with disabilities if I would be interested
and I'm always interested to share my Joseph story so I said absolutely. Great.
Right, so can you tell me about when Joseph was born and the month
months leading up to that.
Well I could actually this month in eighteen days my Joseph will be
twenty two years old.
He has a twin sister Danielle. Danielle and Joseph were born fifteen weeks
prematurely. They were one pound seven ounces, one pound nine ounces at birth.
They spent one hundred twenty days in the neonatal intensive care unit.
Danielle was born screaming. As she's a little girl and now she's a
young woman who's still screaming and my son, Joseph, was breech.
Not breathing and needed to be resuscitated a few times. They both
had an intervention or healer hemorrhages brain bleeds when they were born. And.
Danielle's was a grade two which could have had her have severe disabilities. Joseph was
a grade four and he wasn't expected to survive. So when they
were born we were in shock. Needless to say because they weren't due until August second.
And they were born in which month again? April. April. In eighteen days this month they'll be twenty two
years old. So you know leading up to my pregnancy was short
because I was only twenty five weeks pregnant when I gave birth. So we didn't have time to
plan and you know we didn't have the nursery ready. We didn't have any of that.
So when they were born so soon there, you know, it was a
life changing, needless to say, event. As they said they were spent one hundred twenty
days in the intensive care unit. During that time they had
ups and downs in their development and survival. We did have funeral arrangements
for them by the time July came uh because they weren't gaining
weight and they were just really very very sick for a very long time.
As we would have it, we're fortunate. August seventeenth we were able to take them
home from the hospital.
A whopping four pounds, seven ounces and four pounds
four ounces. Which was actually, you know, they kind of they let
us. we weren't really supposed to, you know, under five pounds you're not supposed to really take them home.
They spent four months in the hospital and we had, my husband I, had to take first aid
C.P.R. classes just so that we could take them home. They had
episodes of apnea. Um, they couldn't breathe and you know
they had to be reminded, come on, breathe, Danielle breathe. You knowthere were a lot of
situations in the hospital that you had us on our edge
Um, Joseph did have more of the
complications than Danielle. He had his grade four intervention
hemorrhage caused him develop hydrocephalus. um, where he
Fluid started to you know gather in the brain. He needed to have a Fontanella.
His fontanella drained. His lung collapsed. um. He had a failure to
thrive and was just really really very sick for a very long time.
He had one episode in July prior to us
making that sad arrangement was that his retinas detached and I got a phone call
at 8 in the morning. " Mrs. Tripodi, if Joseph doesn't have surgery today he's going to be totally
blind as it is, you know, he's going to, we'll be lucky if we save any of his vision." But I had
to go to one hospital, sign him out,  because a doctor didn't have rights. He
was two pounds at the time. They had to transfer him from one hospital to the next. I went to
the next hospital. He was in St Vincent's. We had to
go to Staten Island Hospital. I had to leave my daughter Danielle who had had a difficult night.
.
She was, she had a distended stomach and she she just she was fussing and they said you
know she just wasn't looking good. And I had to take my son but she had to
trim it, travel in an ambulance because he was still on oxygen in an incubator to another
hospital. So he can get the surgery to save his sight. Now at the
time, back in nineteen-ninety-three, we didn't have cell phones.
My husband was at work. And I was by myself. And
He came home to a note on the door. That said Had to go to hospital
Julie may be blind. Wow. Yeah. It was.
We had our, our marriage definitely suffered
without a doubt. But, in any event, the ambulance took
Joseph from St Vincent to Staten Island Hospital. I took the car. I
met them because I had to go sign him in. And I get to Staten Island Hospital and nobody
knows when my two pound baby is. For half an hour.
Nobody could tell me where my son was. I Hhad just left my
daughter, in distress. No idea where my son is. I'm by
myself. And I am
.
Not kind in my
Sailor-like language.
How's that for being politically correct?
And. When they finally found Joseph I somehow beat the
ambulance to the hospital and I don't know how that was possible but I did. I don't know why I took the
ambulance that long to get there but, in any event, when I saw my son the doctor said
Well.  Has the mother been told not to interfere and I'm thinking he didn't realize that I was the mom. Cause I
look young. When I was twenty-seven I looked even younger
and, you know, I was treated as though I was, you know, a teenager who gave birth
to, you know, a child. I didn't know what I was doing. So, the doctors was,you know
has the mother been told not to interfere? and I said "I'm his mother what do you mean told not to interfere and he said
well, should he start to deteriorate when we take him off the oxygen, because, we need to take more of the oxygen to
perform the operation. You have to, you know, he, if
he has if he's going to. He's pretty much is going to die and I told
him in a very unladylike way, I won't repeat it now because I don't think you want
profanity in this. That if anything happened to my son he would be dead
too. And, the nurse that accompanied my son, who's always seen me as
the mom who's always crying, you know.
Obviously I was I was crying. You know my two children were very sick.
She had never seen me get so angry and was like OK
Mrs. Tripodi calm down, he's going to be OK and I said to the doctor said it took St
Vincent's three months to convince me he may live. And now you're going to tell me my son's going to die
. And she she said It's OK Mrs. Tripodi so
P.S. My son had, you know, we're there, we're waiting for the doctor. It was Fourth of July weekend the
hospital was empty. The doctor had to come in from Manhattan to perform the surgery so we're
waiting. I'm by myself and then my husband finally came because he, you know, he didn't
know where to go. Because we didn't have phones. He went to St
Vincents. He didn't go to Staten Island Hospital. So he was frantic in not knowing
what was going on with with his son. So he finally got there and then you know
Joseph had the surgery and one of the things that happened was
he was crying. And I had to hear my son cry throughout the entire surgery.
It's heartbreaking.
I don't need to tell you he was all of three months old two pounds
Crying. And all that I could think of was
OK. If he's crying he's breathing if he's crying he's breathing. If he's crying he's breathing.
And as much as you didn't want him to have the distress, he was breathing
.
So then after the operation,
I became very insistent and this was the start of the empowerment.
that you have to assume when you're a parent of a child with a special need
And I insisted that the next day my son be transferred
back to St Vincent's Hospital. They said "Well Mrs.Tripodi you know he's here already." I
said I want my children in the same hospital. I want them together. They're
twins. I do not want this. I do not want the care of this hospital
because of the way that we were treated when he first came. It'ss not what I want.
And, my son was then transferred the next day back to St Vincent's Hospital.
Finally they came home in August seventeenth and as I said Joseph had quite a few
.
You know trials and tribulations and we immediately started
evaluations because knowing that I had two children with intraventricular
bleeds. My sister-in-law is an occupational therapist and I was blessed that she would
say to me, "Jackie they need to be evaluated. It wasn't enough that they survived.
Now you need to see that they get the support they need so that they can develop."
So she said, you know, do that and I set up the evaluations right after. You know
they got discharged August seventeenth. The first week of September we had the first
evaluations. They started services by the third week of September.
And we had an on-slew of occupational therapy, physical
therapy. Special education services. Speech therapy.
.
The counselor come in so that to help me understand things and we had a
nutritionist come so that I can know what to do as far as you know if they
needed, you know, they had formula this that and because I couldn't breast feed while they were in the I.C.U.
. I. Was barely five months pregnant and you know I
just couldn't produce the milk to breastfeed and while they were in the hospital it just it was it was
too overwhelming to even think about doing that  so. So they were on formula and they did
all that and. Did I mention that my husband and I weren't even married six months
when I had my children. No. We got married in September
I got married I got pregnant in November. And my children were born in
April. Wow. So we're married less than a year.
And, you know, so our first year of marriage was, you know,
But by the time the kids came home, it was our first wedding anniversary and
It was just, um, an amazing roller coaster of,
You know, how are we even going to do this.
How did you meet your husband? Oh, my husband and I were on a blind date you know you know he's
really cute.
And you know we we met on a blind date in July and kind of moved in
together by September and then you know we were together two years and then you're married
Two years after we got engaged so we were together for years before we get married and
.
You know, we we just we knew what we wanted. We were older. He was going to be thirty. I was
going to.. I was twenty seven so we weren't babies. And... But we didn't
expect to have you know when we had our kids that it was going to be all of
that because we live in a glass house.
I don't know if any other family member has shared this, but when you have a child with special needs
or any kind of medical issues and you have people in and out of your house, you live in
a glass house.  You can't fight with your husband in front of everybody. You
have schedules of people coming and going. You you can't sit down to a regular
family dinner, you know. If you leave a piece of paper on the table, you
know, your private information and you trust people because they're in your home and they're
you know they're taking care of your children they're helping you with your children. But there's no privacy
And. My husband and I since our
wedding. Our marriage. And with our children being born so soon
have lived in a glass house and here we are I will I will be married twenty three years
in September my children be twenty two and in two weeks. And I still live
in that glass house because I still have service providers.
in and out of the house. Everybody and their mother has the key to my house because
people constantly coming and going. So. That was the first year
of marriage and the first six months of Dani Joey now right after Joey
And Danny were discharged from the hospital within a week Joseph was re
hospitalized because he had a double hernia. Then he needed another surgery
Long story short by the time Joseph was eighteen he
he's had seventeen surgeries. Wow. and he's always
Smiled. He's he's got a fabulous personality.
He. The
best way I could describe my son's is is um he's motivational. He
motivates everybody to teach is to better not just for him. But
by him. His twin sister has been his driving force because
she has made progress and it's been bittersweet. Because I always say I'm the best I have the best of both
worlds. I have enabled and disabled because Danielle has had met her milestones
and the hard part was that. As Danielle was making her monsoon starting to
stand and starting to walk. My son wasn't.
When my son was. Twenty months he needed brain surgery for the hydrocephalus instead of a
shunt. We opted for brain surgery which was experimental at the time to
alleviate the fluid without giving him a lifelong implant.
He did things because he saw his sister do things. So I've always strived to put
Joseph in an environment where he may not be the highest functioning
individual.
But he is somebody he's going to strike. And he you know there's that
competitive sibling rivalry things that you say and I've always seen Joseph
. Really doing well because to me his has taken that you
know he wants to do with his sisters. There's there's always that. And
. We've been fortunate because although they told me Joseph would never roll over
. Dr said that he would never sit up. Upon the
discharge of them. We went to a neurologist and an analogy set said to me
.
Put him in a residence. And hope for the best and love the one that you can take
care. Referring to my daughter. Needless to
say that was not something that we were going to do. I gave birth to twins are going
to carry this. One. After four months in the hospital and
. A few back and forth visit hospital. Have a strong personality began with.
Them. But we weren't talking about my children. Especially you know
my son and I'm going to say my son my son is probably late
. But. In all fairness
my husband it's my daughter. So. You know he's got the girl and
he was. Saying.
That. Joseph he was.
They said that he would roll over he would never sit up.
When he had the brain surgery. In the hospital room. Now Joey
said his left them.
He now has right on his left hand so that but they put the I.V. in the right hand
.
And. My point was is that I'm an advocate.
After. Four months in the I.C.U. and back and forth was a lot
going on. And I have to get not to be trifled with. I. Just have
had the I.V. in the right hand. He had brain surgery. Who by the way he needed to
see a surgery at the same time because the hernia developed into a large scale. So my
twenty month old. Had stitches in his brain. Stitches in his going
. And was cutting forty's. And one would have to question. Just
. How fair that is. And they put the I.V. in my hand
that he needs to suck his thumb. And he couldn't. And I said
they have to you have to switch the F.A.A. or we can't do that Mr Prodi. I'm not asking you what you can and
can't do. I am telling you what needs to be done so that my son can calm himself.
You're going to do that and you're going to do it now. Well we'll see. Get the
administrator right in there. I want to see that the chief surgeon this is not going to be
tolerated. We're not going to have my son in discomfort.
They change the IP You know it's just it's.
But you have to be that way and. It set the tone.
For my son's entire future. Because.
Having a child with special needs because he's not. Behavioral.
My son receives a diagnosis of cerebral palsy mental retardation. He's legally
blind even though the surgery didn't give him sight thank God. He still has
severely impaired vision. He can't emulate independently he requires
the assistance of a walker. But going back to that story where they said you know
relevant it was set up right after that brain surgery he's in the hospital finally they switched the
I.V.. I'm sitting by his bedside and all of a sudden my son
sitting up. Something they said he would never do. So
we never let anybody tell us. What are some putative.
My son has the will to do a lot. He's not that challenged
. We've said that over the years. He's motivated. He's proud
. And. What we need to do is give him the tools
. To continue. To develop and grow.
So despite his health issues and everything else and you know the beauty of
having a twin sister that just isn't taken because. You know she's not taken any nonsense
you know that's a brother. It's not a kid with a disability that's a brother
she she has been a motivator. And has also
set me straight on many occasions when I don't want to send my son because why I do that you
. Have to do you're different than Joey. No one I. Know not. And you know as
they got older and his time Vault she would be. Now I want to can she want Joe to go
can I sit here but he can't tell me he can't you know he's nonverbal my son
.
He doesn't engage in conversation he's very. In. His own
happy world.
He uses an i Pad now and then you know I wish I had it when he was four because I can only
imagine the abilities he would have to express himself had we had that school
so it's important that technology has done what it's done
because where he is now at twenty two twenty two.
Had he had the technology he has. Available to him. Just those twenty
years ago. I could see a different Joseph. And that's what we can lay
out the constant progress and we can say that anybody plateaus.
There's always there's always hope. I mean and that's one of the things that we always want families to
know is that there's always hope. There's there's a lot of hard work
. But without that hope. You're going to lose yourself to
it. And. We can't let Joey. Half what he has in
his life be for nothing. You know his. His his presence in this world is
making a difference. He may not be out there you know making
touchdowns on the football field with. You know other his cousins
. But he's definitely impacting lives and. That's what we're here for.
So his purpose and he's born with a purpose even though he's disabled
. He has that's his purpose his purpose is so that people can learn. Now I feel sorry for
him because there's no pity there's no. It's it's a purpose to
now look what you can if we can do this you can do. To me
I want to show it can I don't want to good care. I was afraid
. And I go to can I suggest that you can come back and tell me she says
you're like I'm going to tell you. And she says
. What makes you think. My son my brother wants to be with you all the
time. I don't want to be with you all the time. Why should my brother have to be stuck with you all the time.
She was really you know she was twelve thirteen she was being you know a smart alec you know twelve
thirteen year old so. We had to we go to King. And then of
course you know I had to vacation not ten minutes from where the camp
was. You know because after that episode with the hospital
. Needless to say any time Joseph had to do anything
. Even now they have to people have to let me know where he is. I need to know what my
son has so. You know whole cycle sometimes most of the time.
And yeah I was like oh but he you know
I need to know and.
I'm fortunate that we've had fabulous people in our lives that have.
Made. A difference not just for my son but for me. And my husband
. And my daughter. You know it started out with teachers you know.
Jackie Romo was their first teacher. Jill McGrath was an O.T.
. C.N.D. Garris. Alice Newman. That
to me. These these this this teen. When my children came
home. And Pat helped me become empowered. They
educated me in a field that I had no knowledge of. I mean I work for the
phone company. I had no no knowledge of disabilities whatsoever.
I also there was organizations like parent to parent. That got on the
phone with me you know the parent of a child with cerebral palsy got on the phone me when I was.
Beside myself not knowing where I was going to go what I was going to do what to expect
. That type of. Connection. It
gives you not just a hope it's like OK. There's there's more to
this. It's not so terrible. It's not great not
to lie and say you know I would want it. But it's not. It's
not awful it's something that we can make a difference.
I had. Her name was Marie go pull shit on me for three hours.
When my son was first put to a stand but because of my son at one point couldn't bear weight. On
his own so he we had to put him in a standard It looked like if you've ever seen Young Frankenstein when the monster
strapped to a board and all I saw was my son strapped to a board
. And. It. Was devastating
devastating.
I mean my son with glasses he was bilateral earphones he was laid braces you know
we've had you know the pediatric wheelchairs we there's all of that
. And you just kind of went through the motions but then when I saw my son
strapped to a board. Just to bear weight. It
. Put me over the edge and you know he said listen I work with this other little girl the mother's
part of parents parent but she's going to talk to you and my girlfriend I have to say
they took you off the roof.
And she talked me out of the roof. Her daughter was older with cerebral
palsy and she had been there. So. How one
person can change a life. I truly believe that.
It's also set the tone that you get what you give.
And from believing that in this life time. I have been fortunate that I mean
able to give back. I have educated myself to be
a very good advocate not just for my son before other people with disabilities
. Because it's not just about my son. And I mean
right now this is about him. But our entire family isn't just about
. It's about helping the individuals that are in this world. That so
few have a voice and they need force. And I have a pretty big now
. So that kind of if it works out I was fortunate that
. When they were little I would volunteer as part of
. The committee on special education. I would feel. Here
on the P.T.A..
I actually met my best friend who might you know today I call my best
friend because she heard of me being somebody that can abdicate and she
said you know Jackie could you know could you get Jackie to Poti to come in and advocate for my
daughter I didn't know my daughter from an atom. But I I wasn't doing anything and I went to the
meeting and you know after that we met in different meetings in than we are now
best friends. So.
By doing that you know it's you get that back you know and you're able to
help and then you're able to educate. So you know having Joseph in doing
you know so sick so early having them go through all the trials because didn't know how
to share of trials and tribulations and because her her special needs weren't
prominent is Josef's they couldn't be ignored. You know she had to laze in her gross motor
and she had a learning disability. She didn't come out unscathed yet she rose to the
occasion every time. And you know in school she needed that.
Testing modifications and you know we had to advocate for that because her needs weren't as
visible as Josef's.
And you know she and she caught up and she says she's been doing and even now she's
graduating college in you know six weeks she's going to graduate in college but even in
college she knew to get extended time a lot of occasions and stuff like that
. And I've taught her to advocate for herself as well as advocate for her brother.
And she does so. You know this is you know
some of it and I don't know I don't know what else I don't want to Tianjin about anything.
Is there anything else that you need to know about this is all really I mean I know
it's meant a lot for me to be able to sit here and listen you know to your story because I'm learning a
lot myself in this project as a whole as well. Because
. I want. To. Let me just ask you what your day to day is like now
with your son.
Well. Ironically this is being
. This is something that well actually the
buzzing sounds OK. Well
. It's ironic that you should say this because. I'm just going to backtrack two
years two years ago I was diagnosed with breast cancer.
I ended up having to. Hand.
Work and it ended up having that I ended up having like six surgeries in a
matter of five months. You know. The first thought when I got
diagnosed was that I was going to happen to my son I mean my worry about my daughter Don't get me wrong
.
But my son is home with me and he is a twenty four seven kidney Joseph still needs
assistance he needs to be fed toilet it changed. He's one hundred sixty
something pounds he's a big boy. That's it he's a man
. And he needs physical assistance to be lifted. And I couldn't
do that and that's the main anthemic surgery. So
I was fortunate that right after my surgery he went to camp for two weeks it's a good thing my daughter told
me because now I was able to send them to camp without you know really gone crazy.
He's at Camp for two weeks then came home and then we had a staff of people coming in helping.
We have community have workers that come in. And there are
people coming and going you know as I'm laid up with dreams and you know what
kind of you know stitches you know I could barely you know get out of bed
myself. But they were there helping them.
Two years. Fast forward. I've recovered you know I'm cancer free
. I am. You know doing well I've had my last surgery was
useless December and I'm doing OK. I can't let my son
. As a result of. The surgeries I have
scar tissue holes and I can hurt myself
if I left my son and I do a fight and I look I have to he has to be
showered he has to be taken care of. But it's become where it's
not safe for my son. So my son was put on. It's called priority one list
with the state of New York for him to move into a residential group
home. In the end of February.
This was a year year and he was put on the last year and a half ago. I'm. Like a
year after my surgery. We just we can't do it just it's just not
safe. So a year and a half ago we put on the list. There's been no
opportunities and this is where it comes into play. There's no opportunities for individuals
who need twenty four seven to have a place to live. It's just the state is now
funding it. There's nowhere to go. I was
scheduled to speak at a breakfast we had started on disability Council does a part first every
year. They asked if I would speak on you know what it is to have somebody on the list
and has nowhere to go. Ironically and sadly that same week somebody
passed away you know and an opportunity has been presented to my son
. Somebody had to die for my son to have a place to live
.
It's sad and. I'm sad for the family who lost
somebody and. That's the reality
. So as of today we
are now working on transitioning my son to go live in a
residential group home. With other individuals who are lower
functioning than us. Who have much more medical needs than he does
. It is not the ideal location for me to have my son with
it is not what I had planned for him.
It is not. What I want to do at this stage in my life
. But like other families who have people with disabilities I don't have a
choice. I'm. I could advocate left and right for him to live
in a different house but my son needs barrier free. He can't live in a house that had
stairs. My son needs twenty four hour seven day we care
.
A lot of the houses that are out there don't have that.
Had I died on the table which there were complications and I am listed
what would have happened to my son. If something happens to me going forward
. Who says that that decision is then going to fall on my daughter I don't want
that. Should take care of I know she would jump she would take care
. That's. That's her brother. She did not give birth to him. My
husband is just you know of the same mindset you know he actually had a job where he used to travel a lot.
He had to stop working that job and take a cut in pay so
that he could be home to help with Joseph because I can't do it and there's
nothing more humbling. To know that you can take care of your child. Especially
that that's what you want to do and you can't you
physically can't. And I'm no different than a lot of families
who have aging parents and older people with disabilities. And
. I dare I say I'm fortunate that Joseph is going to have this opportunity.
But it's heartbreaking and. It's these past
few weeks and you say day to day every day. I honestly
sincerely cry. I feel sad I feel her
. I wonder if I'm doing the right thing and. I feel like
I'm starting over again. I'm starting over second guessing what am I going
to do. I want to have my son live a happy life.
Am I doing the right thing. I feel like I'm back when he came out of hospital and I
doing the right thing to actually treat it and you second guess yourself and all the confidence that
I've accumulated over the past twenty years being their parent and I
say trying because the first you're doing.
It seems to go right out the window no matter what people
tell you they'll tell you all you find you can do great all you'll be fine
. There's always a pressure. I have to
do this right. I can't afford to screw so I
can't this is my son's life. TO DAY TO
DAY This morning we get up and get Joseph out of bed. Sadly if we don't get him out of
bed in time he soaked because he can't get himself to the bathroom.
He just sleep in polo. He doesn't work while he's sleeping.
He'll get up but he doesn't call out so when he gets up he and his manner and you know
with changing shoes you know changing sheets this morning and changing him. He's a
twenty two year old young man who full grown that empties his bladder
. So I'm cleaning him and you know making sure that he's fine.
Then he goes and he's on his i Pad and he is happy and he's singing
I get ready for work my husband gets ready for work we wait for the van because he goes to an
adult day program on your mark. My son goes to Anya mark because that's an appropriate
program for him. Lifestyles is great but it's not right for him and that's about
knowing the difference of what's right and what's not right. You know your kid.
And so the vandal pick him up take him to program.
I then go to work and look you know I'm fortunate to work in the field and I came upon this job
because I used to volunteer and help. And when there was an opportunity somebody
asked me to help and you know it just it pays it forward I have to say I think
it does pay it forward. So then now at a certain time
on a given day if Joe gets out a program by two thirty three o'clock I have to make sure I'd leave work early
because I have to make sure I get home for him because there's you can't have Grandma get him off the Wii and
Joseph is one hundred sixty two pounds. He needs you to assist him.
Neither my mother or my mother in law have that kind of strength to take characters
so it's just me and my husband's job now
that where he is where he actually works the lifestyles my husband he does support professionals.
It's as does my daughter she works here in the summer but.
We're dedicated to the people that we serve. You know where we're not just about
jobs I mean OK Rob Joseph is first. But we
care we care about happens and we know when we treat somebody
in a program that's how we want our son treated. That's how they you know want a brother treated
respect that's what you give them so you know I'll take care of and then he'll have
community have workers in our community have work will come and work with Joseph on Gholston two different
things take him out and they'll work with Joseph and I
have people Joseph it's been lucky he's very service rich as I said I've become a
very very good advocate for my son. He gets twenty hours of community have a week
so I literally have people in my house seven days a week.
Whether it be from five three four five o'clock in the afternoon till five till nine
o'clock at night Saturday and Sunday. There's always somebody in my house. So
Joseph is always. Has somebody. We're working on goals we don't do
this for babysitting and I want to babysit or they work closely work on how Joseph can
type. Joseph can read Joseph can type. Joseph is
very capable of a lot of things and because he's nonverbal a lot of people
dismiss his abilities and my job is to make sure that they don't
and you can't take anything just because something is quite You can't take for granted but they
can and can't do now. So then you know take care Joseph. The
staff that we have work is what helped us over the showering which is you know relief to me
. But if somebody cancels. If there's a
snowstorm. Here you know I have one of the staff now she's pregnant
she has a baby and you know she's going to get to the point where she can't live Josephine
. So it's just there's that type of stuff going on to now
going forward. We're trying to transition Joseph to go to this group home
. Where you make plans like every week that he goes for a couple hours.
So you get used to his new house. Jess is going to have a new room.
Yes. So. He says he's starting to get acclimated
. As my husband and I are now we've always thought that Joseph was going to be moving
into a resident when we knew that that's going to be the real goal
that now this particular residence at this particular time of my life but you know
when he gets on the pitch you got to take the ball sometimes.
And. JOSEPH. Has been going to a residential respite
once a month for a weekend so he can get acclimated to other people caring for him. We've
done the camp again like I said my daughter has been instrumental in doing that
five years ago we adopted my niece.
Theresa she was fourteen
. We took her in.
And she has been a mainstay is you know somebody who cares about Joseph and
yes our family grew a little bit too and then I have to mention we have two dogs we have
two laboratories we have made it in sunshine and some Chinese jelly stock
and you know Joseph Listen I called me mommy mommy. Like chill sunshine
sunshine and heat up in sunshine.
You want to go with me tonight but he does it with sunshine that is dark and
you know so we have a close knit family and the staff that comes to our house
are now become like an extended part of our family. And Joe and my husband I was
saying like when Joe moves out they're not going to come any more. Where
now for the first time in our marriage. We're not going to have
people in and out of our homes and Danielle is going to be twenty two and Teresa is
nineteen and there are two in a tank and John and I are looking at each other like life is
going to change and that's scary. And
. You know. We don't want to be selfish about Joseph.
Going OK I was being selfish you know to second guess what we're going to do
so but so day in the life this is struggling with
decisions no matter and it doesn't matter what you just live there you know.
Is it being taken care of. Are they making sure that the children between his toes
they you know they are they cutting his fingernails too short you know where they
shave him you know just like you take for granted that you do
that somebody else is going to have to do so and I am such a control freak
control freak.
So to relinquish control is also
very difficult.
Although I can be a fabulous advocate to relinquish that control
. I find to be very difficult because I guess I had so little
control when they were born I was assumed total control
.
And. You know if somebody says we use our powers for good and we
want to make sure that you know I have very confident children are very confident if you
ask my son who's better than you he will tell you nobody. My
daughter has an arrogance about her you can ask anybody who works at last I'll tell
you.
Danielle takes no no.
Sometimes even from the participants because they're people they're not people with
handicapped people and I think that's a good you know with what you guys are
doing I think the most important message is to remember that we're talking about people
and you know I'm grateful to you know share my story. You know
there's a there's a whole thing maybe one day I will write a book and put it on the public library
books. Yeah totally. Maybe it would be fun. So do you have any
other things that you need to know
. I do have one more question and if you could think of mothers like
Result years and years from now maybe before their children are even
born what would you what would you tell them or what would you tell younger version of
yourself.
Try to trust your instincts. Trust your instincts.
You know who you are. When it comes to your child
. You know your child better than anybody else even before
they're born even when you're planning on having a baby and you want to do
things your way. I know I can respect what everybody has done in the past
you know you mother your mother in law or they've all done that done this. Trust your
instincts become confident in knowing that you're a good mother to
start. Because you you've made a choice to bring a life into the world. That's not an
easy choice. So that's that's what I would suggest you do.
And thank you so much for sharing your story and the press. Corps.